consider the kind of people who are
talking about science in this way in
this in this
deified way they're talking about it
like science is god like sciences
is everything the the pro-science guy
andrew cuomo had the worst response to
the virus
the anti-science guy donald trump had a
much better response to the virus
even at the state level people were
always attacking ron desantis in florida
but a much more elderly population than
in new york he's the anti-science
republican
he handled the virus much much better
than the pro-science guy
how does that happen what what about
what about good old science you know
some other things that science knows
science knows that
if a man wants to become a woman and
then injects himself with a lot of
hormones
that will make him happier that's what
we've been told by science right study
just came out
just not true just not true the american
journal of psychiatry issued
a major correction the other day
big retraction reanalysis demonstrates
that neither quote gender affirming
hormone treatment
nor gender affirming surgery this is
when a man basically
is mutilated to look more like a woman
has reduced the need for mental health
services
and then this was put out by public
discourse
is a gender anxious people deserve
better i kind of like that term
people who have anxiety about their sex
it
sounds kind of pc but it's a little more
accurate than than
some of the pc terms for transgenderism
or whatever it is
we were told by science remember settled
science that
uh people who are confused about their
their sex need to mutilate themselves
and we need to do this to children too
we need to inject them full of hormones
and castrate them and and permanently
change their bodies
because it'll make them feel better
turns out no evidence of that
whatsoever as we have been saying from
the very beginning i actually did a
lecture tour that was in part about this
issue called
men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths we were attacked we
were called anti-science well
what does the science really say how
come all those egghead
experts in lab coats are totally wrong
and how come the mean old orange man
who is a vulgarian and a reality tv star
how come he keeps getting things
so right i hope you enjoyed this segment
of the michael knowles show and you
should know on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael show youtube channel because
that just makes sense doesn't it it's
right there it's right there in the name
there is a link in the description below
head on over
subscribe to the michael noel show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video